when revina ala and her family arrived
in Manila from Gaza no one came to the
airport to pick them up she'd been away
for decades the Philippines is no longer
home the government put them up at a
hotel for two nights then left them on
their own with $1300 in
cash we are grateful that they saved our
lives but I hope they will continue to
help us because we are still
filipinos with the help of activists
they ended up staying on this campus
along with dozens of others who fled the
war in Gaza but now they're under
pressure to leave although authorities
aren't evicting the Filipino Palestinian
families staying here at the University
of the Philippines the campus is closing
for the holidays on December the 21st
the concern is that no one will be
around to help them and they're running
out of money now ideally they'd move
somewhere else but the question is where
right's Advocates say the answer isn't
just a place but the support afforded to
refugees a status the Philippine
government hasn't granted them one is to
access to stable housing um uh also
livelihood and employment education uh
access for the children access to
medical
attention officials have said they're
concerned about the safety of Filipinos
caught up in the conflict in the Middle
East 17 crew members of a cargo ship are
still being held by htis in
the two Filipinos held captive by Hamas
in Gaza are free but four were killed in
Israel during the group's attack on
October the 7th more than a dozen
Filipinos are still trapped in Gaza
including Fatima's son who decided to
stay with her Palestinian husband we're
protecting their identities at her
request we get to have proper meals here
but I keep thinking about my family in
Gaza I haven't spoken to them in 4 days
I hope it's not I think I hope it's just
that they've lost internet access my
calls aren't going through either Fatima
says she feels there's no easy solution
for her family it's either a life in
danger or a life in limbo barnab below
Al jazer Manila